so i made it outside this trough
currently
because i cannot physically bathe
in a sit-down bathtub or stand-up shower
area
oh this is slippery
oh because i'm a bigger guy with like
folds and flaps and i have to
move around like almost like a pig bro
what guys welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio i'm your host coffee zilla
and today
i'm just kind of ranting um so me and my
wife
were watching tlc the other day sitting
down for a little meal
coffeezilla's gotta eat too so you know
we're watching
flipping through the channels and like
there's always been one channel that
always has the wildest title something
some youtuber
looking like for clout would come up
with this title right here is called
i'll just eat until i'm dead comma
probably
my 3 000 pound family
what are we doing here exactly tlc and
what i kind of want to say
is look in a time where people
seem more uh sensitive than ever
tlc is coming out swinging with every
episode and i don't understand how
they're getting away with it
it's just blowing my mind to be honest
they are having on the wildest
characters
and these producers have just been given
too much leash i'm gonna be honest with
you
since i met rose i i want to look young
for her
but but seriously you look at some of
this program and you're like what are
they doing here i mean like basically
the premise of the show is like
let's all gawk at this person yeah
everyone's so worried about fat shaming
but tlc's coming on here just
swinging for the fences i don't
understand it and i think this is mainly
why i made the show
because i was like these producers are
sneaky but i see through it you know the
internet detective
i'm not full they pretend to be like
documentarians
when in reality they're purposely
finding and causing
the crazy scenes to happen but they're
pretending like oh well
i'm just objectively capturing this like
you won't see a tlc exec
you know call these people crazy well
except when the tlc boss admits network
has been a freak show
and says they plan to stop that but of
course uh it doesn't stop
because that's where the ratings are
coming from and that's what they're
gonna do
this channel is just wild he's got dead
spots in it i mean it's growing up high
i mean you know if you take more pride
than you are you know maybe
you might get a little more effective
where did you find these people
and can you not see a carnival barker
running down the street saying
see the crazy family i mean the
producers are basically like let's find
the craziest people
that when people are watching it they'll
make fun of it in the comfort of their
own home
we'll just pretend like we're not making
fun of it but we actually are
i don't know pretty weird listen i'm not
getting up on my moral high horse or
anything like that
far be it for me i'm not into like
canceling stuff or anything like that
but even i see these shows i'm like
well i'm just like checking twitter like
is there not a hashtag on this yet
i'm not going to start it that's my
point i'm not going to start it i'm just
surprised
someone has it that's all i'm saying
because it's just
it's crazy so we need to fertilize it i
will i mean
hell i'm trying to fertilize something
maybe if gene was a little bit more
frisky maybe i'd be motivated to get
everything done around him
ah what you know the producers are like
we've got a gold mine here but you know
while they're doing it they're trying to
be professional whatever i would
love to see the tlc bosses talking
behind the scenes because i know
they're not like talking about big ad
and being respectful
i can't believe it looking back through
some of these clips in preparation for
this video
even i was like check this out i i
didn't know this existed name is julius
i'm 62 years old and i'm addicted to
balloons
[Music]
they're beautiful they're soft smooth
delicate i have a connection with them
yeah this is the part where they're like
you know they're straight lace they're
like we're documenting people with weird
obsessions and you're like okay tlc
that's like a
that's like a real thing you could do
right and it's like a serious music
whatever things are gonna take a turn in
a second here and you just gotta imagine
if the producers you know they kind of
steered them in that direction
you know but julius's obsession with
balloons goes beyond shapes and like
it's a serious show
my love for balloons it's also a sexual
love
when i see a beautiful balloon my heart
starts to flutter and i get aroused
you told him to do this you taught him
to listen to the music they have playing
behind here
while they try to pretend like they're
like the type of documentarian serious
people that would document something
it's like no
they literally the producer's mandate is
find the craziest people on the street
and document them for profit
and money a 12 inch and i'll inflate it
to 11 inch
that way it can take a lot of abuse what
i'm holding one you know hugging it stop
i'll kiss it and it's like turn down the
organ i mean don't you like to turn it
down and kiss the woman
okay this is the producer's choice
they're like hey put in the english like
ladies
voice so it seems like we're a serious
show but julius is obsession with
balloons
and then it goes like okay now that we
got it now that we've kind of covered
our bases turn up the old
80s adult movie music go i'm holding one
you know hugging it
i'll kiss it and it's like being in
heaven i mean don't you like to
hug and kiss the woman that you love
lunar is a nickname for people with a
sexual fetish people out there feel the
same way as i do about balloons
but there's two groups of the lunar
group you got the poppers
that get aroused by popping balloons and
you got your non-poppers
okay i just got to say first of all
someone filmed this that's number one
what stop okay don't don't do that but
do you guys see what i'm saying this is
all set up by these producers and
they're like
we got a banger show we found a guy
sexually attracted to balloons yeah
get this i thought the shoe guy was
crazy the balloon guy he's even crazier
you're gonna love him
that's what these people are doing and
it's just it's just insane to me if a
youtuber did this
it'd be like cancelled biggest thing but
tlc does it it's like oh yeah
it's just another day i mean honestly
how can you have a show
where the guy's getting into a trough
you know the producers told him to do
that they're like
hey if we're gonna film you you gotta
have a trough scene that's
first of all so rude but second of all
it's like a sex scene for hollywood it's
like you know in a movie you gotta have
that
the producers for this you know they
pushed him into this i mean have we just
moved the old time like sideshow at a
circus with the carnival barker
said come look at the crazy people have
we moved it onto television where people
just watching the privacy of their own
home seems like a lot like
you know gladiators back in the day now
it's just ufc everyone watches like
people
fight obviously not to the death but
it's like for profit and you can see
the parallels the instincts of society
never really change i don't know
let me know what you guys think a bit of
a different video but yeah just wanted
to ask you guys
in a little rant a little bit thanks for
watching and i will see you guys
tomorrow
wake up and smell the coffee